sir have you broke have you spoken to
your brother since the interview
i haven't spoken yet but i will do and
can you just let me know is that the
royal family a racist family sir
i'm very much not a racist fan prince
william is the consummate professional
when it comes to
being on engagements and he's done this
for a very long time
and i think he was probably very
prepared
for a question to be asked even if aids
had briefed the press
please don't ask anything out of respect
for this engagement that we're on
it's very unusual for actually anyone in
the press line to call out we're
we are often asked not to out of respect
for the member of the royal family
they're there on engagement
and they're working it's very
distracting to have someone shout out to
you
so it's unusual that a question was
asked
um and it was very unusual for prince
william to answer i mean as you saw
when prince charles was on an engagement
earlier this week and
and a member of the press called out
because we're in such an extraordinary
story
they feel it's their job they have to
ask the question prince charles
didn't comment william did he answered
not once but twice and i think that's
very telling
of his mood at the moment he said he
hasn't yet spoken to prince harry
and he also denied that the royal family
was racist i think gives you a pretty
good insight
into how he's feeling at the moment
angry
in those months when i was pregnant all
around this same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
i was told by sources that he is beyond
livid over this interview and the damage
that he has done
not least today he is on an engagement
where he is promoting
mental health and well-being in schools
of course this comes off the back of
megan saying that she didn't get the
help she needed when she
was having mental health problems and
suicidal thoughts
within the royal family and of course
this very toxic
race rail which has exploded in the
aftermath
of the interview the queen's statement
made it very clear that you're not going
to
hear probably from the palace she wants
to take this
issue in-house deal with it in private
um within the family so in a way um
prince william is going against his
grandmother's wish because he has come
out and said
something but i think he said it because
he feels so strongly
he felt he had to say it he feels that
he has to defend
his family and that's what he did today
possibly some might say that william is
just
fueling the narrative i think that's why
palace aids are now being told
no speaking to the media there are to be
no briefings
let's just let's just reign this in but
clearly
prince william felt that he had to say
something on this occasion he just
simply
couldn't stay silent and i think that's
an indication of how strongly he feels
how angry he is and how keen he is to
get that message out
this is not a racist family